welcome back to CBS this morning we're
reporting this morning from lower
Manhattan just yards from where
yesterday's terror attack ended millions
of New Yorkers this morning trying to
get their lives back to normal last
night the city's annual Halloween parade
went on as planned the parades route
came within blocks of where the attacks
started Michelle Miller learned how the
parade became a symbol of strength
Michelle good morning it certainly was
good morning Nora
the NYPD added extra security to this
year's parade which took place just a
few hours after the attack but other
than the boosted police presence this
year's celebration was just like all the
others and that was exactly the point
[Music]
with unified spirit costume revelers
marched down New York 6th Avenue in the
city's annual Halloween parade
when you heard about Halloween you said
gotta be down here yeah we're out here
every year's New York is strong New
York's gonna come through pull through
no matter what happens we're always
gonna be there we're always gonna have a
good time
[Music]
additional police were assigned to the
parade route to help protect the 44 year
old tradition New York City Mayor Bill
de Blasio said life must continue as
normal
we have been tested before as a city New
Yorkers do not give in in the face of
these kinds of actions did you feel safe
found out here for sure everything's
blocked off the security is more than
ever I never be my lane before three
month olds abroad and sorry was
celebrating his first Halloween parade
along with his parents who were
undeterred by the violence earlier in
the day you weren't afraid to come out
I was Neeson but I was not that much do
not to go for the parade yeah
[Music]
because this is our country or we can
say this is a city like we can trust and
we should not be afraid of such
incidents you have to get out and you
have to enjoy life autumn Cromwell was
driving up from Maryland when the attack
occurred did you have second thoughts
about coming tonight no with the New
World Trade Center shining over the
parade route the day's events were not
lost on the lifelong New Yorkers Jesus
and Katie goryeo's being out here
through all the things that we've been
through you know
Times Square 9/11 all that and we want
to come out and show New York solidarity
and even though it's a horrible tragedy
we still feel that you can stop what
we're doing and this year's parade is
just one example of New York City
showing its resilience the annual New
York City Marathon is scheduled for this
Sunday and I know you know it will go on
as planned it will go on as plan and
it's interesting to think about even
just this block has about three schools
there's a school there there's a school
you know Stuyvesant just down the block
and so everybody's back getting their
kids to normal back into school and
that's it it's people are going on as
planned
resilient Thank You Michelle thank you
all right let's send it back now to
Charlie and Gayle and beyond in studio
57 Thank You Norah I know intellectually
that is the way you have to look at it I
totally get it but sometimes it's just
very difficult well and I wanted to
bring up a plaque because you know I
live right there in PS 89 is right
across the street from where I live and
I noticed this I took the picture of it
last year on September 11th I walked by
this every day it was a plaque from
September 11th dedicated to the heroes
and the first responders who came there
to the aid of the children who witnessed
such horrific you know terror and you
just think of the kids that came out of
that same school yesterday
it's all the same thing and you have to
thank first responders once again for
coming to their babies you can't say
that in yeah yeah